non
françois mitterrand appelle les
congressistes de rennes à préserver
l'unité du parti socialiste édition
spéciale du 19/20 avec paul amar en
direct de rennes 1800 25e jour de
détention pour terry anderson le
journaliste américain en otage depuis
cinq ans au liban n'a toujours pas été
libéré réactions dans le monde entier
enfin c'est pas l'homme qui prend la mer
c'est leur outil touche teurs portrait
de type on à mesure 21 du globe se lance
dans quelques minutes
bonsoir ça tanguait tout à l'heure à 19
heures ça tangue encore un peu plus avec
eux le discours de jean pierre
chevènement qui succèdent à la tribune à
laurent fabius vous l'entendez vous le
voyez en même temps que moi et vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure à 19h les
mots-clés unités a dit françois
mitterrand rassemblement a dit michel
rocard synthèse a surenchéri pierre
mauroy ces mots sont revenus comme un
leitmotiv tout au long de l'après midi
comme si les socialistes voulait
conjurer le sort comme s'il voulait
exorciser le mal qui les guette et qui
s'appelle tout simplement l'éclatement
c'est en effet un congrès de tous les
dangers auxquels le 19 20 a décidé
d'insister et qu'il vous fait vivre en
direct ici du parc des expositions à
rennes
cela peut paraître paradoxal les
socialistes ont toutes les raisons
d'être heureux
ils sont au pouvoir ils ont tous le
pouvoir mais il semble douter même s'ils
disent le contraire
nous avons entendu tout à l'heure michel
rocard et pierre mauroy qui ont lancé un
appel à l'unité
écoutons maintenant la réponse de
laurent fabius il n'y a pas ici d'un
côté de bons militants et de l'autre de
moins bons en fonction de la motion
votée il n'y a que des militants
socialistes à égalité
les amours et d'ambition avec
nous y sommes il faut un parti
socialiste urnes où on notre seul débat
porte sur la meilleure façon de servir
celui ci dans le futur rassemblement
renouveau recomptait sachons garder dans
nos mains rassembler le talisman de la
jeunesse du rassemblement et de
l'égalité et à ces conditions là je vous
le dis au bout de la route sera tous
ensemble pour nous tous ce gouvernement
et partis rassemblés au bout de la route
pour nous tous mes camarades mes amis le
succès unité a ajouté laurent fabius oui
mais unité mitterrandiste il n'a pas
voulu se dévoiler mais cet avertissement
semble clair il s'adresse à lionel
jospin et pierre mauroy laurent fabius
n'acceptera pas une éventuelle alliance
au sein du parti avec michel rocard il
n'acceptera pas ce qu'il appelle un
éclatement au sein de la famille
socialiste
en tout cas cette année traitement qu'il
ne faut plus exclure c'est à qui
rejettera sur l'autre la responsabilité
d'une éventuelle division du courant
mitterrandiste on en parlera plus
longuement si vous voulez élise vers
19h45 à tout à leur église
on a tout à l'heure paul 109 jours 8h48
seul en mer c'est au coeur de la nuit
dernière que titouan lamazou a gagné un
fantastique paris et battu un grand
record
flash back sur l'arrivée de l'homme du
jour donnant thierry bercot il était
attendu le matin puis l'après midi
c'est finalement en pleine nuit que
titouan lamazou a terminé sa folle
épopée une centaine de vedettes sont
venus accompagner les derniers milles
d'écureuil d'aquitaine certains n'ont
pas hésité à prendre leurs plus frêles
embarcations non éclairé pour vivre
pleinement cet événement unique au
risque de se faire est prônée par de
plus gros bateaux fauser durant
lesquelles titouan se débat pour
franchir la ligne d'arrivée le vent
mollit terriblement ralentissant la
marche du monocoque 8 noeuds 7 6 5 puis
4 ne tutoie on doit tirer des bords pour
atteindre le but final la bouée de nouch
balisant l'entrée du port des sables
d'olonne après 8 vers le bord le sort en
est jeté
titouan lamazou vient de boucler la
boucle en cinq jours 8h48
il est minuit 5
jean-yves terlain entoure nos champions
philippe poupon son frère et florence
arthaud aussi sans oublier ses proches
son frère et surtout sa petite fille zoé
à bord d'une autre vedette sa mère
entonnent le chant des montagnards avec
le plan des béarnais c'est le bonheur
tout le monde exulte bousculade sur les
pontons pour recueillir les premières
déclarations du vainqueur
et puis la victoire est fêtée comme il
se doit au champagne
voilà pour l'ambiance biance de la nuit
dernière après son exploit d'hier la
maison n'a plus à le prouver il est un
grand marin mais titrant à plus d'un
vent dans sa voile il est aussi peintre
et écrivain portrait signé alain leblond
lamazou c'est un nom le 16 mars 90 mais
hors du marin qui connaît l'homme qui
vient d'accomplir pareil exploit
berne est d'origine citoyen passe son
enfance au maroc et fait de la peinture
une véritable passion c'est plus tard à
marseille que son professeur d'art
l'initient à la mer sa première
traversée vers les caraïbes il la doit
au bateau stop
ensuite c'est le service militaire sur
pen duick avec le grand à paris lui
l'inconnu dubern à décrocher cette place
d'équipier qu'il va garder comme une
seconde peau jusqu'à 29 ans personnage
introverti fragile il n'a pas confiance
en lui
mais un jour il quitte pourtant tabarly
pour vivre dans un village de l'atlas
marocain c'est là qu'il écrit son
premier roman le trésor de l'atlas plus
mûr moins vulnérable il voit enfin ses
capacités de marin solitaire il se
projette à louhans 87 pour la course
autour du monde avec escales où il
termine second
ils ne rêvent plus lui l'artiste il
prend enfin sa carrière en main avec sa
gueule de corsair et sa silhouette
râblée l'anti star est devenue hyper
motivé ce globe challenge il le veut on
connaît la suite
et s'il dit c'est un luxe de passer
quatre mois sol il n'oublie pas qu'il
est papa d'une petite zoé
il se souviendra toujours des fraises
qu'elle lui a apporté à l'arrivée de thé
109 jours
voilà et puis enfin sachez que loïck
peyron qui a longtemps talonné lamazou
tout au long de ces quatre mois de
course en solitaire arrivera cette nuit
aux sables d'olonne à l'étranger
cinquième année de détention pour terry
anderson le tâche des journalistes
américains et toujours détenus au liban
depuis hier ses proches sont tenues à se
rassembler pour ce triste anniversaire
une veillée de 24 heures et ce matin sa
compagne lui adresser un message par
l'intermédiaire d'une cassette vidéo
la vie sans toi est un enfer
affirme-t-elle sur des images de leur
petite fille reste à savoir si terry
anderson entendra le message
terry anderson était enlevé à beyrouth
le 16 mars 86 c'est le tage occidental
qui détient le triste record de la plus
longue captivité au liban mais ce soir
il reste encore dix sept otages et c'est
pour eux que jean paul kauffmann et
roger auque ont entrepris une action
symbolique ce matin à paris reportage
embrasse perrin philippe pisteurs
le noir absolu les chaînes assis à même
le sol et le silence tout comme terry
anderson en ce moment même dans sa geôle
quelque part dans beyrouth
triste anniversaire il ya cinq ans le 16
mars 85
le journaliste américain était enlevé
une heure d'actions symboliques des deux
anciens otages destiné à rompre le
silence
c'est le silence et il faut le répéter
c'est le silence qui prolonge le
calvaire d été des otages américains
britanniques et suisses allemands y en a
beaucoup on se mobilise aujourd'hui
c'est très bien et comme je le dis c'est
encore une fois c'est entre les
anniversaires peu que le problème se
pose à ccc la houle et les familles
bon et doivent de manière morose ingrate
se battre pour briser le mur du silence
lieu choisi pour cette action
l'ambassade d'iran appellent à
l'inévitable influence de la république
islamique
et effectivement les négociations qui
sont ce qui se déroule actuellement
entre tous les états concernés mais je
pense qu'en faisant cela on montera à
l'iran que l'on n'oublie pas que l'iran
est directement responsable c'est aussi
une manière de faire pression pour que
les négociations allaient plus vite
elles sont dans une phase terminale mais
cette phase terminale peut très bien
durer encore des mois
il reste 17 occidentaux repris en otage
au liban
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
c'est le verdict rendu cet après midi
par la cour d'assises de paris à
l'encontre d'alfredo astiz tortionnaire
argentin était accusé de séquestration
illégale et de torture envers deux
religieuses françaises
le kapitan astiz a été condamné par
contumace et outreau le symbole c'est
aussi une première judiciaire mondiale
reportage francine raymond est enrayée
darche est depuis 13 ans les familles
des deux religieuses françaises
attendent et que justice soit dite
parce que comme le disait soeur alice
domon quelques jours avant sa mort on
n'a pas le droit de terre les horreurs
de la dictature
si le procès du capitaine astiz qui a
préféré rester à buenos aires a eu lieu
aujourd'hui à paris sait qu'alfredo
astiz n'a jamais été condamné dans son
propre pays
surnommé l' ange blond de la mort astiz
s'était fait une spécialité pendant la
dictature infiltrer les organisations de
défense des droits de l'homme en 77 il
réussit à se faire admettre dans le
cercle de celle que l'on a baptisé les
folles de la place de mai il approche
ainsi alice domon et léonie duquet
deux religieuses françaises venues
apporter leur soutien aux familles des
milliers de victimes de la répression
arrêté en décembre 77 les deux femmes
seront torturés pendant quinze jours ici
dans les sous sols de l'école supérieure
de la marine de buenos aires les
témoignages contre le lieutenant astiz
promu depuis capitaine sont accablants
un argentine le dossier astiz est classé
comme tous ceux des officiers
subalternes poursuivis pour violations
des droits de l'homme
jamais jusque là accepté pour les crimes
liés à la deuxième guerre mondiale
un étranger n'a été jugé
france sont des crimes commis dans son
propre pays sur deux ressortissants
français
c'était donc une grande première ce
verdict expliquera les avocats de la
partie civile c'est le devoir
d'ingérence des états lorsqu'il ya
violation des droits de l'homme et c'est
l'honneur de la justice française
depuis cet après-midi le capitaine
assises et placé sous mandat d'arrêt
international est donc condamnée à être
prisonnier dans son propre pays puisque
tous les pays vit avec la france par une
convention d'extradition ce qui n'est
pas le cas de la renfile lui sont à
terre à 36 heures des élections libres
et démocratiques en rda les allemands de
l'est ont un dernier regard sur une
campagne électorale très agitée une
chose est sûre à la veille de ce scrutin
le parti communiste est très bas dans
les sondages
ambiance à la veille de ces élections
historiques
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
laurence piquet et robin cowboys
si le kurde et touristes bas encore pour
la relève de la garde
berlin est vit déjà à l'heure du
satellite dernières grandes manoeuvres
médiatique à deux jours du scrutin
toutes les plus grandes chaînes du monde
sont là devant la chambre du peuple
dans le hall d'entrée déjà la
réunification seuls sont admises les
télévisions des deux allemagnes
élections 90 sous le règne de la haute
technologie ouest allemande carte
estimations dimanche les 18 heures sur
le terrain on quitte confort et
professionnalisme transports chaotiques
méthodes artisanales dernier effort à
quelques heures de la fermeture de la
campagne le coffre
bien chargé en voûte ici pour la ixic à
quelques 200 kilomètres sur les murs les
berlinois découvre la profusion de
partis on engouffre un maximum de tracts
affiches on hésite devant l'abondance de
carte postale
plus étonnant encore ici à la mairie de
berlin le président élu de la commission
de contrôle des élections est un
écologiste de 23 ans il est responsable
de plus de 1000 bureaux de vote
matériel électoral rudimentaire une urne
en carton et le nouveau venu cette
isoloirs enfin image symbole de
l'amateurisme de ces élections ce spot
électoral
la belle histoire d'un allemand de l'ess
sauvé par l'amour et par un nouveau
forum
la politique qu'en france cette fois
avec le congrès du parti socialiste à
rennes nous en parlions tout de suite et
nous rejoignons paul amar harel oui ils
lisent depuis quelques minutes le
congrès a pris un tour un peu plus
polémiques avec les interventions de
jean pierre chevènement et de laurent
fabius
bien sûr les orateurs ne manquent pas et
vous l'entendez de conclure leur
discours par des appels à l'unité tous
les orateurs le fond mais il suffit de
voir ce qui s'est passé en coulisses
depuis l'aube jusqu'à ce soir pour se
rendre compte de vie notre temps d'une
autre différence et d'un autre ton avec
ce reportage de philippe ii cf qui est
de christophe camille diaries après une
nuit au havre en sommeil mais riche en
conciliabule etc tractations la famille
mitterrandiste au grand complet se
donner rendez vous pour un petit
déjeuner rideau pour les images de la
tasse de thé de la réconciliation car
l'heure est plutôt aux déchirements
les protagonistes semblent vraiment
d'humeur massacrante
ils se parlent diront certains c'est
déjà bien les gens public c'est autre
chose
oui d'un congrès un peu étrange par
rapport à d'autres que nous avons connue
c'est un congrès où nous sommes trop
séparer c'est un congrès où il ya trop
de bruits de couloir que le congrès
s'est pas vraiment
avec les militants ou un jeu j'essaye
employés profit d'un parti de militants
et je pense que là il ya certes un
détournement au déjeuner chacun reste
entre soi pierre mauroy menu sandridge
le premier secrétaire prépare son
discours qu'il prononcera dans moins de
deux heures en présence de rocard qu'il
aimerait bien rallier à sa cause
pour les autres valse de cortège
officiel oui ça débarque pour les
bagnoles là-dedans gars d'éclat pour lui
apparemment la synthèse version non
droit ne tracasse pas jean poperen qui
réunit ses fidèles laurent fabius et c
est lui qui au moins auront profité des
charmes de la bretagne profonde sur les
bords de la vilaine
ces dissonances se retrouve au sein même
du gouvernement c'est un comble il y a
ceux qui soutiennent laurent fabius et
ceux qui soutiennent pierre mauroy du
négoce pain ou même le michel rocard ses
ministres sont ils le trouble et
pourtant témoignages recueillis par
jérôme cathala et haut niveau ce qu il y
à la chaleur de la salle la chaleur de
la parole il y a toujours la raison qui
finit par l'emporter c'est pourquoi je
prends rassemblement d'effacer ce
congrès est par nature un lieu de
rencontre et je pense que cette journée
qui est une journée disons le de
positionnement le permet lui notamment
pour les membres de ma motion
d'entretenir le dialogue avec avec tout
le monde les membres du gouvernement
sont des amis l'esprit d'équipé et de
communauté d'idées l'emportent sur
l'esprit de controverses qui en même
temps fait partie de la démocratie mais
je ne crois pas qu'ils les
contradictions
je dirais même plus ces débats
contribuer au fonds a à nous réunir et à
constituer entre nous je dirais cet
esprit d'équipé facile aux adultes
ça s'appelle la langue de bois
les militants par le plus vrai et
n'hésite pas exclu mais eux leur
désarroi reportage de philippe de ses
skis et de dominique duchateau des
militants pour le moins dubitatif hier
jusque tard dans la nuit et ce matin le
spectacle n'était pas à la tribune
lui-même dans la salle mais dans les
coulisses combine alliance les militants
n'apprennent plus dans la presse que
dans les réunions leur courant et ce
n'est pas du goût de tout le monde que
nous
le jeune militant j'arrive dans un
congrès fédéral je vois ce qui se passe
je rends ma carte c'est pas possible
c'est pas avec cela qu'on va pouvoir
mobiliser la la la la colle à dépenser
j'ai pas l'impression effectivement on
s'engage vers la reconquête électorale
du parti socialiste eh oui où est le
socialisme dans tout cela certains
militants sont inquiets et s'interrogent
des doutes s'emparent est il de l'esprit
des congressistes devant le déchirement
de la famille mitterrand disque le bord
du jean seris survivre en eau mais sa
base populaire secrétaire
moi j'aime beaucoup pierre mauroy mais
je fais un choix d'idées je fais un
choix aussi pour des méthodes un
fonctionnement plus dynamique et aussi
plus démocratique
voilà pourquoi je suis engagé avec
laurent fabius mais cet après-midi les
tensions l'amertume des uns les
rancoeurs des autres se sont à l'instant
apaisé lors de la lecture du message de
françois mitterrand toute la famille
s'est rassemblée à lahore dans un choeur
d'applaudissements unanime un instant
peut être trop rares d'ici la fin de ce
congrès
alors monsieur le maire vous écoutez
tous attentivement on se demande
vraiment ce qui les divise à parts à
part l'ambition peut-être oui mais c'est
formidable parce qu'on vit vraiment ce
congrès en direct la situation a
pratiquement évolué entre la 1ère partie
la deuxième partie d'une seule main en
première partie on a eu les appels à
l'unité et en deuxième partie la réponse
donc de tanus et on semble quand même
ces appels invités ont plutôt été
entendu au moins pour la synthèse
mitterrandiste alors qu'est-ce qui
aujourd'hui les divisent encore à la
fois peu et beaucoup de choses peu de
choses dans les thèmes parce que tout ce
qui était sujet de le sentiment de
crispation sur l'europe sur le budget de
la défense sur les rythmes le
développement social on s'aperçoit
finalement très peu de différence le
risque deux choses essentielles les
hommes autour de qui la synthèse et puis
la conception du parti
c'est pratiquement les seuls points la
journée où il ya eu de véritable
polémique des sifflets dans la salle
c'est quand on a parlé de la
construction du parking la ya une
véritable divergence
en tout cas on a cité comme une roland
ce soir risque où elle était en public
c'est quand même beaucoup plus sain que
tu sais que gilles yabi
toujours est il revient à ce que disait
charles de gaulle il n'y a que la
querelle de l'homme qui vaille c'est
bien ce qui se passe ici au sein du
parti socialiste vous retrouverez tous
les envoyés spéciaux de l'a3 évidemment
un soir 3 et dans toutes les autres
éditions
je tiens à remercier nos amis de la
station de rennes qui l'ont aidé à
réaliser cette édition spéciale en
direct du parc des expositions qui se
déroule en ce moment même le congrès du
parti socialiste à belize le corps d'une
fillette de 11 ans a été retrouvé cet
après midi dans la banlieue de
montpellier les policiers avaient tenu à
garder secrète la disparition de cécile
qui d'après les premiers éléments de
l'enquète aurait été enlevé et assassiné
par un maniaque sexuel tout de suite les
autres faits marquants de l'actualité
commentée par jean françois grégoire fin
du blocage du péage de la turbie près de
nice et les routiers français baisse
avec une grève de la peur après les
menaces proférées par les chauffeurs
italia contre les camions qui passent
raid en italie mais il ne devrait pas y
avoir de retour à la normale à la
frontière avant le début de la semaine
prochaine
ça va faire comment ce week-end je sais
pas une débrouillent autrement su faire
des chèques
le mouvement de grève des transporteurs
de fonds à marseille paralyse le
convoyage de billets de banque et déjà
plusieurs guichets de la cité phocéenne
sont à sec
les retraits ce week-end seront
difficiles mais certains distributeurs
seront encore en service
à saint-etienne les policiers
poursuivent leur enquête
après le démantèlement d'un réseau de
trafic d'armes un artisan armuriers et
un brigadier de police ont été arrêtés
ils rssi fait des armes de guerre pour
les réintroduire dans un circuit dont
profitaient les hommes du milieu
une trentaine d'armes ont été saisies et
les policiers ont retrouvé les canons de
revolvers volés par un employé à la
manufacture d'armes de saint-etienne la
disparition de jacques paoli l'un des
plus grands journalistes radio de france
mort des suites d'un cancer
jacques paoli avait participé à la
création d'europe 1 avant d'en devenir
l'une des voix les plus connus il avait
66 ans
en football il a suffi d'un petit but à
l'équipe d'algérie pour remporter cet
après-midi la coupe d'afrique des
nations face au nigéria l'algérie qui
n'avait jamais remporté cette épreuve
inutile de vous décrire la joie des
supporters didier balèze n'a pourtant
pas résisté au plaisir de passer une mi
temps dans chacune des deux communautés
vous allez le voir c'est du sport il est
15h30 la communauté maghrébine s'apprête
à vivre un moment historique
l'algérie rencontre le nigeria en finale
de la coupe d'afrique des nations les
pronostics vont bon train à quelques
centaines de mètres un foyer d'afrique
noire une salle de télévision
on est rentré plus tôt du travail pour
participer à l'événement
ici quel que soit le pays d'origine le
coeur penche plutôt côté nigeria est la
raison l'emportent
mais je parle ce que je vois là dedans
je viens et vous pensez qu'ils vont
gagner à la fin du match je passe bien
parce que il a pas que le nigeria les
pronostics d'ahmed s'avère judicieux car
la 38e minute ou deux gènes couvre le
score d'un tir splendide 80000
spectateurs sont debouts fou ivres de
joie
1 0 à la mi temps au foyer on est triste
chez jamal patron algérois l'optimisme
grandit je crois que c'est la gérer
qu'il va gagner
fin du match victoire des vert et blanc
1 0 le rêve devient réalité c'est la
première fois que l'algérie remporte le
trophée depuis sa création la fête
commence des milliers de kilomètres les
séparent le sport les unit pour toujours
avec une carole merle décidément très en
forme la française a remporté ce matin
arrêt en suède sa cinquième victoire
consécutive en terminant première de ce
super-g ans elle décroche par la même
occasion la coupe du monde de la
spécialité
c'est bien évidemment prometteur pour
les jeux olympiques d'albertville de 92
carole merle sur ces images
pour sa cinquième victoire et voilà ce
journal est maintenant terminée à 20h30
thalassa georges pernoud et son équipe
reviendront bien sûr sur l'exploit de
titan lamazou prochain rendez vous avec
l'information soir 3 présenté par marc
hautement à 22h30
l'info sur l'a3 le week-end c'est eric
achats on se retrouve lundi à 19h avec
paul amar bien sûr bonsoir
nous